à notre collègue le président bruno
retailleau plus monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mesdames
messieurs chers collègues
une fois de plus la vague est monté une
fois de plus l'hôpital est submergé une
fois de plus le président a parlé une
fois de plus le parlement est prise en
otage et une fois de plus pour la
troisième fois la france est confiné
monsieur le premier ministre ont
quelques instants vous allez nous
demander de voter mais c'est un vote
pour rien parce que c'est un vote sur
rien vous allez nous demander de voter
sur des annonces qui ont déjà été faites
vous allez nous demander de voter sur
des mesures à prendre qui ont déjà été
prises
oui hervé marseille et raison nous avons
l'électricité la télévision et nous
avons effectivement regarder c'est à
nancy hier la télévision
mais à quoi bon voter si tout est décidé
et il y un paradoxe parce que c'est trop
facile de vouloir nous faire voter quand
tout est décidé et lorsqu on aurait aimé
avoir des votes nous le refuser souvenez
vous c'était au moment du débat pour une
reconduction d'état d'urgence et le
parlement propose est ici le sénat un
vote
lorsqu'il fallait projet d'un mois le
confinement
c'était normal c'était un contrôle
démocratique et vous nous aviez refusé
ce vote monsieur prévu notre ministre de
la santé nous l'avait refusée pour notre
bien puisque il nous avait dit à
l'époque
c'est pour empêcher l'embolie des
chambres merci pour sa sollicitude
mais c'est là que le vote aurait pu être
utile
en réalité je pense que quand je parlais
de prise d'otage du parlement vous
souhaiter que le parlement cet
après-midi le sénat soit une sorte de
faire valoir et bien le sénat mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas le faire valoir
de l'exécutif ou du président de la
république et vous n'êtes pas et vous
n'êtes pas et nous ne sommes pas des
greffiers appliqué du verdict de jupiter
c'est une évidence la vème république ce
n'est pas le président parle à la télé
et le jour d'après le parlement
s'exécute dans l'hémicycle ça n'est pas
ça la vème république
je voudrais je voudrais avec de nombreux
collègues et compris président de groupe
partagez ce que nous avons sur le coeur
vous disposez avec votre gouvernement de
pouvoir extrêmement étendue très très
étendue la contrepartie de ces pouvoirs
immenses
ce serait de veiller au contrôle
démocratique et notamment parlementaire
et pour autant vous vous ingénié
méticuleusement à marginaliser le
parlement vous avez recours aux
ordonnances depuis le début du mandat
des miles macron pas le vote mais celui
des mâles macron 298 ordonnance vous
allez me dire oui mais c'est plus rapide
non c'est plus long il faut nous l'avons
démontré ici 436 jours pour une
ordonnance et il faut de 135 jours pour
la loi la loi est plus rapide quelle est
la différence
ce n'est pas la vitesse la différence si
le contrôle du parlement pas là le
recours aux ordonnances cours le recours
bien entendu au conseil de défense à
l'opacité des conseils de défense
le recours aux procédures législatives
expéditive tous les textes sauf la
bioéthique tous sur la procédure
accélérée parce que le temps du
parlement et un temps perdu encore une
fois et puis la floraison de ces comités
théodule eh bien je pense qu'on ne peut
pas se réjouir même pour vous même pour
l'exécutif je vous mets en garde
parce que la démocratie c'est aussi des
contre-pouvoirs et je pense que c'est
une illusion d'enjeu
heureuse que le président de la
république conforte les français dans
cette croyance naïve d'un homme seul
capable de tout capable de tout prendre
en charge parce que lorsqu'il y as
défaillances dans la prise en charge et
que parallèlement les mécanismes
démocratiques parlementaires ne sont
plus au rendez vous qu'est-ce qui se
passe
la nature elle a horreur du vide dans ce
face à face dans cette libéralisation de
la politique dans la suppression de tous
les intermédiaires y compris pour le
parlement qu'est ce qui se passe la
nature a horreur du vide il ya d'autres
mécanismes qui se met en place
la démocratie c'est rendre des comptes
et aux heures les plus graves notamment
première guerre mondiale
relisez votre histoire cette démocratie
n'a pas été un obstacle à la gestion
d'une crise énorme
elle était une ressource quelle source
et mécanismes qui se met en place ce
sont les réseaux sociaux où chacun peut
pour un temps vouloir devenir un
procureur à fouquier tinville vous le
savez bien
mais quand on veut le face à face au
peuple on risque cela un précédent
intervenants le disait il ya quelques
minutes
et quelle est l'autre mécanisme qui se
met en place
puisque la responsabilité démocratique
devant le parlement est insuffisant
c'est que les ministres sont appelés à
la barre et je le désapprouve cette
judiciarisation comme j'ai désapprouvé
des réquisitions à 6 heures du matin
d'un ministre de la santé qui a autre
chose à faire
évidemment je vous renvoie la
sollicitude dont nous avez rendus sur
l'embolie mshare le ministre de la santé
et cette judiciarisation non mais cette
judiciaire dit mais vous si on est au
coeur du mécanisme c'est le premier
serait coûté mois un instant parce que
c'est important
au moment où nous en sommes dans notre
démocratie cette judiciarisation elle
encourage la bureaucratisation pourquoi
parce que quand on fait un protocole
vous avez tous les niveaux fischer le
risque pénal et qui vous évidemment le
parapluie tout grand judiciarisation
égale bien entendu toujours plus de
bureaucratisation voilà ce que je veux
vous dire et c'est important vous
l'entendiez alors vous avez eue nous
vous avons confié d'ailleurs des
pouvoirs très étendus
mais quand avez vous fait pour quel
résultat
je voudrais prendre 2 exempt
dont d'autres collègues ont déjà parlé
les lits de réanimation c'est important
puisque c'est ce qui vous permet de
piloter en tout cas les mesures de
freinage et sa de ce point de vue on le
comprend et puis la vaccination
qu'avez vous fait de ses pouvoirs
étendus énorme pour ce qui concerne les
lits de réanimation j'ai écouté comme
tant d'autres prisons de république
j'ai entendu comme le 28 octobre dernier
avant le second le deuxième même des
records finement le chiffre de dix mille
lits c'était le même chiffré hier donc
il ya un problème ou la promesse ou la
promesse du 28 octobre était une
tromperie ou alors si elle n'était pas
une tromperie c'est simplement que
l'engagement ne s'est pas réalisé
puisqu'on est toujours assez d'emilie et
s'est dit me dit on ne les a pas puisque
vous savez très bien que cela découle de
déprogrammation la déprogrammation c'est
la perte de chance pour ce qui devait
être opéré qui ne le seront pas je
discutais avec plusieurs chefs de
service de grands hôpitaux parisiens
ces derniers jours eh bien il me disait
tout ce qu' il faut pratiquement le
personnel de deux blocs opératoires pour
créer un lit de réanimation c'est énorme
certains disent même que lorsque vous
soigner un patient pour une quinzaine de
jours qu vide
c'est sans doute 150 à peu près personne
patients qui devait être opéré et qui
devront avoir leur opération repoussé ce
sont des pertes de chance pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a rien fait pourquoi
j'avais entendu présent république dire
parler du chiffre de 7000 personnels
soignants infirmiers infirmières et est
aussi médecin qui aurait été soignés
mais où sont ils
où est la réserve sanitaire sur le
terrain je vous assure
pour ce que l'on connaît pour nos
départements pour nos régions la réserve
sanitaire
on ne la voit pas pourquoi en parler et
ça fait un an qu'on en parle qu'avons
nous fait de ses pouvoirs
qu'avez vous fait de ses pouvoirs
énormes qui vous ont été confiées et sur
la vaccination
je vous ai entendu mois ci au mois de
décembre parler d'un chiffre mi avril
c'était 14 millions
3 est désormais pour la mi mars et
désormais c'est 10 millions pour la
mi-avril mais parce que monsieur le
ministre premier ministre il ya une
valse des chiffres il ya une valse du
calendrier que y'a pas un français qui
s'y retrouvent je vous assure je vous
assure tellement il ya eu de changement
de pied et vous allez dire très bien
c'est l'europe
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu un haut
responsable allemand d'ailleurs il ya
quinze jours me répondent oui mais mieux
vaut vacciner lentement mais vacciner
dans un cadre européen
ça c'est l'idéologie et ça ça n'est pas
entendable par nos compatriotes c'est
vous qui êtes en charge de la protection
des français de la nation française
aucun commissaire européen ne fera pour
le peuple français ce que un élu du
peuple peut faire pour protéger les
français
ça me paraît une évidence évidemment
donc ce pouvoir quand vous a confiée
vous l'avez exercer mais pour peu de
résultats j'entendais la fameuse phrase
quand je me regarde et quand je me
compare donc quand on se compare mes
chers amis on se désole plus tôt nous
sommes en matière de vaccination au 51e
rang ça veut dire qu'on fait moins bien
que le chili cole maroc que la serbie
peut la hongrie que tant d'autres pays
l'allemagne et à un peu plus de soixante
quinze mille morts avec 82 millions
d'habitants nous nous allons arriver à
cent mille morts et chacun d'entre nous
a une pensée pour ceux qui sont plus là
pour leurs familles qui souffrent
toujours
mais c'est ça les résultats c'est à cela
qu'on doit juger une politique même si
je sais que les circonstances sont
difficiles
évidemment et je le dis ici aujourd'hui
je le répète à cette tribune
voilà ce que nous attendons nous
attendons une efficacité mais je pense
qu'on ne peut pas toujours pointé la
responsabilité de la technocratie de la
bureaucratie
il ya eu dès le départ un manque de
volonté au plus haut niveau de l'état
au même moment alors évidemment je vais
parler de monsieur tron en main il dit
je suis confiant pour crier un vaccin
d'ici la fin de l'année quelques jours
après le présent république française
lui répond personne de sérieux personne
de sérieux ne me dis que nous
disposerons d'un vaccin à la fin d'année
donc quand nous sommes dans cette
organisation hyper présidentialiser
hyper centralisé
et que la tête ne crois pas en
l'occurrence à cette possibilité de
disposer des vaccins il ne met pas en
tension toute la chaîne de commandement
et faut pas s'étonner ensuite qui est
diluée
la vérité elle est là c'est d'abord un
manque de volonté politique manque de
volonté politique et manque de stratégie
il ya deux stratégies gagnantes dans le
monde
on l'a vu la stratégie des démocraties
asiatique le zéro co vide on n'a pas pu
le faire donc de l'efficacité du traçage
manque d'efficacité pour l' isolement
mais eu moins de 20000 morts et puis il
ya une autre stratégie gagnante c'est la
vaccination de peace avait loupé la
première marche dans la gestion de
l'épidémie
c'est le royaume uni c'est les états
unis et d'autres c'est la vaccination
rapide mais massive et nous n'avons eu
ni l'une ni l'autre des deux stratégies
nous avons eu certes à paris la
bureaucratie ajouté à la technocratie
bruxelloise et voilà le trou de souris
d'éveil macron s'est transformée pour
beaucoup de français en souricière mes
chers amis voilà et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce que veulent les
français c'est qu' on puisse leur donner
des preuves de l'efficacité et qu'on
reconstitue l'antidote qui est la
confiance la confiance vous la
reconstituer à trois conditions la
première c'est l'efficacité
j'en parlais il ya quelques instants
s'il faut commander des vaccins en
dehors de la procédure européenne faite
le l'ambassadeur d'allemagne nous a ici
au sénat c'est dans un compte-rendu
confirmé qu'il y avait eu la commande de
30 millions de father andorre n'y a pas
d'interdiction
faisons le pourquoi ne le ferions nous
pas bien donc l'efficacité d'abord et
arrêtons de considérer que chaque vad et
la dernière anticipons en matière de
formation en matière de lits de
réanimation
première condition à la conscience
l'efficacité deuxième condition
l'humanité je l' ai déjà dit l'autre
jour il y a eu et vous avez sans doute
vu ces témoignages de personnalités
artistiques culturelles qui témoignent
qu'ils prennent la voie des familles qui
ont été créés des très belles lettres
attention à ne pas laisser mourir dans
la solitude dans les ehpad
mais aussi derrière des portes closes de
pitau ça se ferait peut-être de loison a
mais chaque semaine nous
des témoignages cet aspect humain il est
déterminant et enfin il ya la lucidité
la lucidité de reconnaître ses limites
chacun d'entre nous nous avons nos
limites chacun d'entre nous monsieur le
premier ministre
mais dans une crise le pire et c'est la
limite qui ne doit pas être franchie
c'est justement de ne pas reconnaître
c'est lui et je pense que un prison
république
même lorsqu'il et jupiter même lorsqu'il
est un expert une universelle un
épidémiologiste en même temps qu'un
philosophe même quand il est doté de la
plus belle intelligence
il est doté d'une pensée complexe même
lui seul ne peut rien seul c'est
absolument une évidence donc je crois
que les institutions représentatives de
notre démocratie doivent être respectés
ne fait pas du sénat ou de l'assemblée
nationale un théâtre d'ombrés ce lieu
ce lieu d'une fausse concertation ce
lieu d'un simulacre de décision nous
allons comme d'autres ne pas participer
au vote
ce geste politique ce n'est pas un
mouvement de mauvaise humeur ce n'est
pas un caprice c'est simplement un
message
la démocratie représentative et chers
amis c'est l'assurance pour tous les
français quel qu'il soit quelles que
soient leurs sentiments politiques c'est
l'assurance que le sort de tous ne
repose pas dans les mains d'un seul
voilà ce qu'est la démocratie voilà
pourquoi la démocratie a été inventé
alors oui il nous faut reconstruire
ensemble monsieur le premier ministre et
nous sommes disponibles la confiance
mais la confiance par la preuve par
l'efficacité et j'ose espérer que cette
nuit sans fin aura une aube une aube
nouvelle
et comme l'a dit le président de
république que cette aube ce sera une
ode un joli mois de mai vous n'en avait
pas parlé je les entends dû en parler
j'espère que vous croyez à cette
promesse présidentielle d'ailleurs si
vous croyez à ce que en mai les choses
aillent mieux
en mai c'est à dire que les bars les
restaurants rouvre pourquoi nous ferions
nous pas si il n'y avait plus d'élection
ce serait donc l'échec de la promesse du
président république d'hier soir en tout
cas nous voulons une nouvelle espérance
et je pense que c'est en abandonnant les
vieux démons
mais c'est surtout en écoutant le
parlement
et c'est surtout en redonnant confiance
aux français que vous y parviendrez
merci merci merci monsieur le président
je vais maintenant donner la parole aux
présidents taux de mayo rey pour le
groupe les indépendants